INSTITUTIONS AND COMPANIES THAT
ARE RESEARCHING COVID-19.
BRET?
>> RICH EDSON, THANK YOU.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHERE THINGS
STAND RIGHT NOW IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS AND
CHINA AS WELL.
WE ARE JOINED BY THE MAN IN
CHARGE OF THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE, VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT TO OPEN
UP SCHOOLS THIS FALL?
>> WELL, WE HAD A VERY IMPORTANT
SUMMIT TODAY, GOOD CONFERENCE
CALL WITH THE NATION’S GOVERNOR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MADE IT
CLEAR, AS WE OPEN UP AMERICA
AGAIN WE NEED TO OPEN UP
AMERICA’S SCHOOLS AND FROM EARLY
ON IN THIS PANDEMIC, THE CDC HAS
BEEN GIVEN GUIDANCE ON HOW WE
CAN SAFELY MITIGATE AND OPERATE
SCHOOLS, NEW GUIDANCE WAS ISSUED
LAST WEEK BUT I MUST TELL YOU
THAT PARENTS AROUND AMERICA,
TEACHERS AROUND AMERICA, WE
TRUST LEADERS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK, CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO
OPEN OUR SCHOOLS UP AGAIN.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, 47 STATES HAVE
ALREADY ISSUED PLANS AND
GUIDANCE FOR DOING JUST THAT AND
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM.
WE THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO GET
AMERICA BACK TO WORK, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO GET OUR KIDS BACK
TO SCHOOL AND ALL OF THAT CAN BE
DONE AS WE CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT STATES THAT ARE SEEING
RISING CASES HAVE THE TESTING,
THE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND HAVE THE MEDICINES
TO BE ABLE TO CONFRONT THIS
PANDEMIC EVEN AS WE OPEN UP
AMERICA AGAIN.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY THAT HE WAS GOING TO
PRESSURE THE GOVERNORS TO OPEN
IF THEY DIDN’T, I JUST WANT TO
ASK YOU WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
IF THE GOVERNORS AS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE LOCKDOWN MAKE
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT THEIR STATE IS
DOING OR GOING THROUGH AND WHAT
HEALTH EXPERTS ARE TELLING THEM,
WHAT DOES THAT PRESSURE LOOK
LIKE?
HOW DOES IT MANIFEST?
>> I THINK TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
BROUGHT TOGETHER TEACHERS,
HEALTH CARE LEADERS, WE ALL
REFLECTED ON WHAT I BELIEVE IS
THE OVERWHELMING OPINION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT WE’VE GOT
TO GET OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL.
SO TODAY WAS VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT DOING LIKE HE IS WANT
TO DO, FOCUSING ON THIS
IMPORTANT NEED BUT I MUST TELL
YOU, WHETHER IT BE THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF PEDIATRICS THAT
PUT OUT A STATEMENT LAST WEEK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLASSROOM LEARNING, WHAT WE ARE
HEARING FROM EDUCATORS AND
PARENTS AROUND AMERICA, WE CAN’T
LET OUR KIDS FALL BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW,
YOU ARE A PARENT, YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT IT’S FAR BEYOND ACADEMICS,
THAT MILLIONS OF FAMILIES RELY
ON OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS, MANY OF
OUR CHILDREN THAT STRUGGLE WITH
EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES ARE
DISABILITIES, THEY RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES AT SCHOOL.
ADD INTO THAT NUTRITION, ADD
INTO THAT OTHER WAYS THAT WE
SERVE OUR KIDS, IT’S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT WE GET BACK TO
SCHOOL AND THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS
EFFORT ON THAT.
BUT ALSO, WORK WITH OUR
GOVERNORS TO SEE THOSE PLANS
IMPLEMENTED.
THE ONE POINT WE MADE TODAY WITH
GOVERNORS ON OUR CONFERENCE CALL
IS THAT THE CDC HAS ISSUED A
RENEWED GUIDANCE LAST WEEK ON
HOW WE CAN SAFELY OPERATE OUR
SCHOOLS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE IT CLEAR, WE
DON’T WANT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE THE REASON YOU
DON’T REOPEN YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS, SCHOOL OFFICIALS,
GOVERNORS IN STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO FIND A WAY TO SAFELY
REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN DO THAT FOR
MOST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Bret: MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I
THINK THERE IS UNITY THAT
PARENTS WANT THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL, I THINK YOU HEAR THAT NO
MATTER THE IDEOLOGY, THE
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY BUT DO YOU
BELIEVE IS THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY THAT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
KEEP SCHOOLS CLOSE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS?
YOU TALK TO THESE GOVERNORS,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
>> LOOK, LET ME LEAVE THE
GOVERNORS OUT OF IT FOR JUST A
SECOND AND SAY WHEN WE HEAR SOME
WORD ABOUT TEACHERS UNIONS
BEGINNING TO SAY THAT THEY’RE
NOT GOING TO BE WILLING TO COME
BACK IN SOME JURISDICTIONS
AROUND THE COUNTRY, LOOK.
WE ALL OUGHT TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS.
AS I SAID AT THE TOP, TO OPEN UP
AMERICA WE’VE GOT TO OPEN UP
AMERICA’S SCHOOLS, IT’S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
I DIDN’T EVEN MENTION THE FACT
THAT THE ACADEMIC WELL-BEING,
THE HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF OUR
KIDS IS A PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE.
BUT LET’S REMEMBER WORKING
FAMILIES, SINGLE PARENTS.
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
TO WORK FULL-TIME THIS FALL,
WE’VE GOT TO HAVE THESE SCHOOLS
UP AND RUNNING AND WORKING.
WITH THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR
TODAY, SHOT ACROSS THE BOW,
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO PLAY
POLITICS ON THIS THING IS ON
FAIR NOTICE THAT WERE NOT GOING
TO PUT IT AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OF FAMILIES, OF
EDUCATORS KNOW WE CAN GET BACK
TO SCHOOL, GET BACK SAFELY,
K-12, HIGHER EDUCATION AND OUR
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY.
>> Bret: TODAY THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST PULLED OUT
OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
NOT SURPRISINGLY JOE BIDEN PUT
OUT A TWEET SAYING HE WOULD JOIN
IT IF HE GETS ELECTED ON THE
FIRST DAY BUT YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICAN LAMAR ALEXANDER PUT
OUT THIS STATEMENT MOMENTS AGO
SAYING "I DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A GOOD HARD
LOOK AT THE MISTAKES THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION MAY HAVE
MADE WITH THE TIME TO DO THAT IS
AFTER THE CRISIS HAS BEEN DEALT
WITH, NOT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT,
WITHDRAWING U.S. MEMBERSHIP
COULD INTERFERE WITH CLINICAL
TRIALS ESSENTIAL TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF VACCINES, AS WELL
WHICH CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS OTHERS
IN THE WORLD NEED.
>> IT’S APSLEY
THE RIGHT TIME TO NOTIFY
CONGRESS, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION LE
BY NOT INFORMING THE WIDER WORLD
THIS PANDEMIC AS IT BEGAN IN
CHINA, GIVING ILL-FETED ADVICE
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY, IT --
THERE HAVE TO BE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THIS.
BUT I’LL BE HONEST WITH YOU, I’M
NOT SURPRISED JOE BIDEN WANTS TO
KEEP US ROPED INTO ANOTHER
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION,
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY CONDEMNED
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ACTIONS WHEN
HE SUSPENDED ALL TRAVEL FROM
CHINA AT THE END OF JANUARY.
YOU KNOW, THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID THAT, I CAN TELL
YOU FIRSTHAND, THAT BOUGHT OUR
NATION AND VALUABLE TIME
REINVENT TESTING, SPEND HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
PURSUING MEDICINES,
THERAPEUTICS, AND VACCINES.
IF JOE BIDEN WOULD’VE HAD HIS
WAY WE LITERALLY WOULD’VE HAD
TENS OF MILLIONS OF MORE CHINESE
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY AND
SPREADING THE PANDEMIC AND
PUTTING MORE AND MORE AMERICANS
AT RISK.
RIGHT DECISION ON THE W.H.O.,
JOE BIDEN WOULD’VE MADE THE
WRONG DECISION IN JANUARY.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT CHINA IN JUST A MINUTE BUT
JUST TO WRAP UP THE CORONAVIRUS
AND YOU LEAD THIS TASK FORCE,
OBVIOUSLY THE NUMBERS ARE GOING
UP, THE THE PRESIDENTS WANTS US
FOCUS ON DEATH RATE AND WE DO.
THE ADMINISTRATION SAID THE
PRESIDENT CONSTANTLY DOWNPLAYS
THE SERIOUSNESS OF COVID-19 AND
SAY HE SPEAKS IN OPTIMISM, NOT
REALITY.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
YUKO WE HAVE TESTED ALMOST
40 MILLION PEOPLE.
BY SO DOING WE SHOWCASE 99% OF
WHICH ARE TOTALLY HARMLESS.
>> WE HAVE TO START BASICS AND
LEVEL WITH PEOPLE, SUGGESTING
THAT IT’S NOT DANGEROUS IS IN
ITSELF A DANGEROUS MESSAGE.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY SERVED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH YOU,
HEALTH EXPERTS SAY IT’S JUST NOT
THE CASE THAT ONLY 1% OF CASES,
COVID CASES THAT THEY ARE
DANGEROUS.
IT’S MORE THAN THAT SO IS THERE
A MESSAGING PROBLEM HERE WITH
THE VIRUS?
>> LOOK, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AN
OPTIMIST, HE BELIEVES IN THIS
COUNTRY BUT HE ALSO BELIEVES THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO HAVE
THE WHOLE STORY.
THE REALITY IS, BECAUSE OF WHAT
THE PRESIDENT DID IN SUSPENDING
ALL TRAVEL TO CHINA WE WERE ABLE
TO STAND UP A NATIONAL RESPONSE
THAT HAS SAVED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS AND PERHAPS EVEN
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN LIVES.
WE HAVE RISING CASES RIGHT NOW
ON THE SOUTH, I WAS IN TEXAS AND
ARIZONA AND FLORIDA LAST WEEKEND
THE GOOD NEWS IS AS WE TOLD
GOVERNORS AGAIN TODAY, WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT ALL THE
TESTING THAT THEY NEED.
WE HAVE NEW THERAPEUTIC
MEDICINES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WE HAVE LITERALLY
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT SUPPLIES
AND RESERVES EVEN THOUGH I HEARD
FROM THE GOVERNORS THAT I
PERSONALLY MET WITH THAT THE
EFFORT AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL HAS
BEEN SO STRONG THAT HOSPITALS
ACROSS THE SUN BELT HAVE MORE
THAN ENOUGH PPE PAY WHAT THEY
DID REQUEST OF US AND THE
PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED WAS TO SEND
ADDITIONAL DOCTORS AND NURSES,
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT IN ALL FOUR OF THE LARGER
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
SO FAR AND WE WILL DO IT IN ANY
OTHER STATES THAT REQUEST IT BUT
WITH THE PRESIDENT WANTS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW IS THAT
OUR NATIONAL RESPONSE, WHETHER
IT BE TESTING, PPE, SUPPLIES AND
MEDICINES HAVE SAVED AMERICAN
LIVES.
MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AGO WE WERE
LOSING 2,500 AMERICANS A DAY AND
THERE WAS A DAY JUST RECENTLY
WHERE WE ONLY LOST 250
AMERICANS, THAT’S A 90%
REDUCTION IN FATALITIES.
IT’S A CREDIT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, ALL THE SACRIFICES
THEY’VE MADE, TO OUR HEALTH CARE
BUT ULTIMATELY IT’S A CREDIT TO
OUR NATIONAL RESPONSE WHICH HAS
SECURED ONE OF THE LOWEST
MORTALITY RATES IN THE WORLD.
>> Bret: YOU TALK ABOUT
MORTALITY, DR. FAUCI SAID TODAY
THAT IT’S A FALSE NARRATIVE TO
TAKE COMFORT IN THE LOWER RATE
OF DEATH BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY THINGS DANGEROUS ABOUT THIS
DISEASE, DON’T GET YOURSELF INTO
FALSE COMPLACENCY.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE
MORTALITY RATES BUT SOME EXPERTS
ARE SAYING THEY DRAGGED BEHIND
WITH THE CASE IS GOING UP, THAT
THE DEATH RATES, LET’S HOPE NOT.
BUT THEY MAY FOLLOW.
DR. FAUCI ALSO SAID THAT STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD
MANDATE MASK-WEARING.
ESPECIALLY IF THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK THERE, DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT RECOMMENDATION?
>> WELL, WHAT WE AGREE WITH IS
WHATEVER STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS DETERMINE IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR AREA.
FOR THE VERY BEGINNING,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WE ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT OUR GOVERNORS, WE ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS IN TAKING THE STEPS
THAT THEY DEEM MOST APPROPRIATE
BUT THE FACT THAT DR. FAUCI, WHO
HAVE WORKED WITH VERY CLOSELY
NOW FOR FOUR MONTHS, I CAN
ASSURE YOU THERE IS NO
COMPLACENCY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE PRESIDENT ISN’T
REFERRING TO THE LOWEST
MORTALITY RATE IN THE WORLD IS A
REASON FOR COMPLACENCY, HE WANTS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN
COMBATING THIS PANDEMIC BECAUSE
OF ALL THE SACRIFICES THEY MADE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT STATES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY
ACROSS THE SUN BELT, HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND SUPPLIES TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER WITH
THOSE INCREDIBLE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND HOSPITALS TO KEEP
THOSE LOSSES LOW.
AGAIN, THE LOWEST IN THE WORLD
BY SEVERAL MEASURES, A CREDIT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE ARE
NOT GOING TO RELENT IN OUR
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STATES HAVE THE TESTING
RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE,
HAVE THE EXTRAORDINARY MEDICINES
MEDICINES, STEROID TREATMENT,
THAT ARE REALLY BRINGING REAL
RELIEVED AND RESTORING HEALTH TO
AMERICANS.
WE OWE IT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO GIVE THEM THE WHOLE STORY AND
WILL YOU SEE CASES RISING AND
FRANKLY SOME IN THE MEDIA WANT
TO FOCUS EXCLUSIVELY ON RISING
CASES, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS IN THIS
PANDEMIC, IT’S BECAUSE OF ALL
THEY’VE DONE AND WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE SURE EVERY STATE AND EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT IS RISING CASES
ON RISING POSITIVITY RATES HAS
EVERYTHING THEY NEED AT THE
MOMENT.
>> Bret: I WANTED TO GIVE YOU
TIME TO TALK ABOUT THAT, IF YOU
WOULDN’T MIND I DO WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT CHINA, DO YOU HAVE A
SECOND ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
♪ ♪
>> Bret: AGAIN JOINED BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THANK YOU FOR
STICKING AROUND.
ON CHINA, SECRETARY OF STATE
POMPEO SAID YOU WERE CONSIDERING
THE BANNING OF THIS CHINESE
CHINESE-OWNED APP, TIKTOK.
THE FBI DIRECTOR SPOKE VERY
AGGRESSIVELY WITH ME, YOU’VE
SPOKEN OUT A COUPLE TIMES
AGGRESSIVELY ABOUT CHINA, IS
CHINA OUR ENEMY?
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION THAT
CHINA IS A STRATEGIC COMPETITOR
WITH...
>> Bret: LOST THE FEED THERE
FROM THE VICE PRESIDENT, LET’S
SEE IF WE REESTABLISH THIS
CONNECTION.
DON’T THINK WE HAVE HIM UP,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, CAN YOU HEAR
ME?
OKAY, WE WILL TRY TO REESTABLISH
THAT CONNECTION.
HERE WE GO, SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT.
YOU WERE SAYING, ON CHINA?
>> NO ONE’S BEEN TOUGHER ON
CHINA THAN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, FROM
VERY EARLY ON THIS PRESIDENT
STOOD STRONG TO RESET AN
IMBALANCED TRADING RELATIONSHIP
THAT PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS
ALLOWED TO DEVELOP IN A WAY THAT
WHEN WE TOOK OFFICE HALF OF OUR
INTERNATIONAL TRADE DEFICIT WAS
WITH CHINA, THE PRESIDENT STOOD
STRONG.
HE ALSO MADE IT CLEAR THAT WE
ARE GOING TO DEFEND OUR
STRATEGIC INTEREST IN THE
REGION, TWO AIRCRAFT CARRIERS IN
THE SOUTH CHINA TO BE SEE AS WE
IS EVIDENCE OF OUR COMMITMENT TO
PRESERVE FOR FREEDOM OF
NAVIGATION BUT WHETHER IT’S THE
STAND ON WALL HUAWAI OR TIKTOK,
ARE GOING TO PRESERVE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
FROM BEING COMPROMISED BY THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND SO
THE DASH THESE ENTITIES, PERHAPS
EVEN TIKTOK, THAT REPRESENT A
THREAT TO THE PRIVACY OR
SECURITY OF THE COUNTRY WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE A STRONG
STANCE.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT
UP THIS WEEK, DID NASCAR MAKE
THE RIGHT MOVE BANNING THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG?
>> LET ME SAY, WE RESPECT THE
RIGHT OF PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
TO MAKE THE DECISIONS THAT THEY
DEEM APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND FOR THEIR FAN
BASE BUT, YOU KNOW, AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE PRESIDENT AS HE
SAID AGAIN TODAY BELIEVES IN
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, WILL ALWAYS
STAND UP FOR THAT FOR EVERY
AMERICAN BUT I MUST TELL YOU
THAT BEING A PART OF AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT SAW THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE EVER
RECORDED FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
THAT WE HURT AGAIN TODAY AT OUR
EDUCATION SUMMIT HAS MADE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS AND
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES, WORKING TO OPEN
THOSE SCHOOLS AND ALL OUR
SCHOOLS AROUND AMERICA AS WE
SPEAK ON EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES
OPPORTUNITIES, I THINK PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY BE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
OR ANY AMERICANS LOOKS AT THE
RECORD OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND KNOWS THAT THIS IS A
PRESIDENT WHO IS COMMITTED TO
BEING PRESIDENT FOR ALL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SEEING ALL
AMERICAN PEOPLE LIVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Bret: THE STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI REMOVED THE
CONFEDERATE SYMBOL FROM ITS
FLAG, THE REPUBLICANS IN THAT
STATE SAY IT’S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO, SOME OF THOSE REPUBLICANS
THOUGHT THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
AT LEAST IN WHAT WAS TWEETED OUT
BY THE PRESIDENT, YOU’RE SAYING
THERE’S NOT?
>> THERE IS NOT AND WE FULLY
RESPECT THE DECISION MADE BY THE
PEOPLE OF MISSISSIPPI GOING
FORWARD AND QUITE APART FROM THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF THE CONFEDERATE
FLAG, I JUST THINK IT’S A
QUESTION OF, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID AT MOUNT RUSHMORE, WE ARE
GOING TO DEFEND THE GREAT TO
COME ALONG, STORIED HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
WE’VE BEEN ON A RELENTLESS
JOURNEY TOWARD A MORE PERFECT
UNION, WE WENT THROUGH A
TERRIBLE CIVIL WAR, 600,000
AMERICANS DIED ON BOTH SIDES TO
END SLAVERY, WE SAW THE ADVANCED
IN MY LIFETIME OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AT GREAT COST
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE ALL OF THE IDEALS OF
THIS COUNTRY AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF EVERY AMERICAN
OF EVERY RACE AND CREED AND
BACKGROUND AND THIS PRESIDENT
AND A VERY REAL SENSE, I PROMISE
YOU, IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DEFEND AMERICA AND OFFEND
AMERICA’S GREAT TRADITIONS
AGAINST THOSE WHO WANT TO TEAR
DOWN STATUES, WHO WANT TO ERASE
OUR HISTORY, WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM OUR HISTORY AND
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER AND THAT’S
ALL WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A MORE
UNITED UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Bret: WE REALLY APPRECIATE